arte
qué palabra tan difícil de definir
tan extraña tan abstracta tan subjetiva
pero tan tan maravillosa la verdad es
que a mí me encanta yo le escucho y se
me pone la piel chinita y me dan ganas
de cantar bailar como lo que hace
rayones en la pared o lo que sea pero me
gusta
la verdad es que a pesar de que llevo
mucho tiempo haciendo teatro encontré el
significado de esta palabra hace unos
meses
y es lo que hoy vengo a contarles
hace dos meses estaba en un salón
repleto de desconocidos no sabía sus
inquietudes sus inseguridades sus miedos
estaba en mi primer día de escuela en el
aeropuerto
la fila de las tortillas
estaba frente a mis primeros alumnos de
teatro
y la verdad es que estaba muy nerviosa
yo nunca había dado clases no sabía que
podía enseñarles que no podía enseñarles
que les iba a gustar que no no tenía ni
la más remota idea de por dónde iba a
empezar
la cosa es que mis alumnos eran muy
especiales
algunos de ellos no podían hablar
algunos de ellos no podían escuchar o
leer
y estoy casi convencida de que la mitad
de mis alumnos nunca se aprendió mi
nombre
pero no importaba todos y cada uno de
ellos tenían ganas ganas de expresar
ganas de sentir de mostrar de mostrarse
tal y como eran
y eso era lo más importante
ese día ocurrió un milagro en ese salón
de repente todos éramos artistas y no
importaba que podían o no podían hacer
yo estaba dispuesto a adaptarme a todos
y cada uno de ellos si no podían hablar
podrían mover su cuerpo si no podían
escuchar podían escribir no importaba
cómo pero al final todos lograron hacer
arte
y fue así como descubrí mi propio
significado del arte para mí
el arte es para todos
definitivamente creo que el arte es para
todos y no solamente porque yo lo digo
porque yo lo haya experimentado así de
hecho estudios de la universidad de
toronto han demostrado que la
apreciación del arte es un proceso
biológico natural estamos hechos para
apreciar el arte para hacer arte
piénsalo por el momento hemos hecho arte
desde la prehistoria pintábamos con
sangre de animales bailábamos cantábamos
a los dioses hacíamos de todo con lo que
tuviéramos al alcance de nuestras manos
entonces si necesitamos hacer arte y el
arte ha estado con nosotros desde la
prehistoria porque nos sigue dando tanto
miedo intentarlo ahí no es que yo no
bailo no hombre yo nadamás canto en la
regadera o cualquier otro tipo de cosa
que hayamos escuchado ve
este comentario definitivamente creo que
son excusas la realidad es que debemos y
podemos hacer arte
así que ahora para demostrárselo les voy
a contar la historia de rené magritte
me gustaría que observar en este cuadro
por un segundo la verdad es que yo
cuando lo vi lo único que podía
preguntarme era
porque es tan famoso solamente son dos
personas con el rostro cubierto
la verdad es que reúne madrid no era el
mejor pintor no estaba enfocado a que
sus pinturas parecieran fotografías
todo cambia cuando te cuentan que cuando
rené magritte era un niño su madre murió
se suicidó en un lago
cuando ella salió del lago cuando
sacaron el cuerpo del lago
lo único que rené magritte pudo observar
era el rostro cubierto por el vestido
que traía
y por eso todas sus pinturas tienen el
rostro cubierto
doloroso cierto
creo que lo más magnífico de este pintor
es que encontró un significado su propio
significado del arte y hace que todos
nosotros lo sintamos también
llevo más de 10 años haciendo teatro y
he visto gente haciendo milagros he
visto a gente muy introvertida que se
atrevió a bailar gente que salió de la
regadera para tomar clases de canto y se
volvieron en grandes cantantes me he
visto a mí siendo más empática más
cuidadosa más amorosa e incluso
preocupándome más por los demás
y es que el arte no solamente nos cambia
a nosotros también nos hace pensar en
los demás
y yo creo firmemente
que cada vez que salgo de una obra de
teatro sé que todo vale la pena
cuando alguien me dice oye gracias me
hiciste llorar aunque sea una sola
persona porque creo que eso es lo que
realmente nos conecta eso es lo que hace
que el arte realmente sea valioso saber
que yo pude hacer reír o llorar o contar
un chiste tan malo como el de las
tortillas
finalmente haces que la otra persona
sienta algo
y creo que estamos o sabemos que estamos
vivos porque sentimos y porque queremos
expresar algo
pero no es fácil la verdad es que es una
aventura y hay que tener una resiliencia
tremenda
hay que tener el valor de enfrentarse a
uno mismo enfrentarte a tus miedos a tus
convicciones a tus metas a tus sueños a
tus inseguridades a todo aquello que te
hace ser tú mismo
y la verdad es que puedo decirles que
todavía me da miedo intentar ciertas
cosas todavía me da miedo bailar
creo que es parte del proceso y creo que
vale la pena y el arte es terapéutico
o nunca sabes cuando alguien se va a
sentir de la misma forma que tú con lo
que tú estás representando
sea un cuadro o sea una canción
cualquier forma de arte que estés
expresando la realidad es que nunca
sabes
con quién estás compartiendo ese
significado
y creo firmemente que el día en el que
todos
conozcamos de esta forma tan profunda el
día en que todos nos demos cuenta de que
la persona que está sentada a tu lado
también tiene sueños también se enamora
también sufre
y siente y es un ser humano como tú
creo que será el día en donde la
verdadera empatía comience y en donde
nos demos cuenta
de que estamos aquí para ayudarnos para
conectar para impulsarnos para ser
mejores yo creo que el arte es para
todos
y espero que cuando salgan de la sala
ustedes también lo crean que tengan
ganas de bailar de pintar como locos y
que cuando escuchen la palabra arte en
su cabeza hay algo lo que sea pero que
haya un significado un significado que
ustedes se atrevieron a ir a buscar que
salgan de su zona de confort que no se
limiten y si vengo y les digo todo esto
si les platico de lo que el cerebro
trata con el arte de rené magritte
si estoy aquí para enfrente de ustedes
es porque creo que tienen el potencial
y que tienen sentimientos mensajes lo
suficientemente poderosos para cambiarle
la vida a alguien
y es por eso que es tan importante que
busquen su propio significado del arte
pero sobre todo no olviden
que el arte es para todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]